I was 30 before I made any money out of
this business before that I was having
to live in very very different
circumstances and I was born in
different circumstances and they left my
mark on me and I'm not trying to be ice
cube here right from Gray's in Essex
it's sort of a bit like dull Ice Cube
your idea
like Ice Cube you know how rough it was
oh my God I was Straight Outta Compton I
had to knit back I'd left the gas on so
you don't have to like you know make
excuses for your struggles just because
you're white like white people have to
deal with a lot sometimes the industry
doesn't buy their special sometimes we
gotta listen to minorities complaints
that's annoying for just five dollars
you can get Andrew some earplugs so that
he couldn't block off the complaining of
the minority members who is kindly put
into this show I'm in the tile all sorts
of people here two of whom are plainly
not white and even the one who is white
has got a very good natural hair lift
thank you so much